منذر هالمسلسل جعفر العمده الجديد منذر
يدور في اطار تشويقي اجتماعي حدثنا اكثر
عنه عن فكرته
هو المسلسل كله له علاقه
في صراع الوجود ووجود هذا البني ادم
ومكانته ومكانه وهذا اصعب الصراعات انه
كيف كيف تثبتي في مكانك
بيجي في لحظه مجموعه من الناس بدهم ياخذوا
هذا المكان
فهون بتصير المشكله العميقه ومن له العقيه
في المكان هذا كمان شيء صعب طيب
مهم الانسجام اليوم ما بين نجمين كبيرين
الانسجام الانساني قبل الانسجام الفني
جدا مهم جدا مهم لانه
بيكون الخوف على الثاني
نفس خوفك على نفسك الخوف ليطلع المشهد في
في في
اناقته يعني انا مثلا في مسلسلات معينه ما
بكونش انا انا ومحمد ولكن بكون همي عليه
وهو عم بينعرض المسلسل او هو اثناء
التصوير يعني هيك وانا مع هاي العلاقه
دائما مع الممثلين تطور مرحله اللي
بنحكيها الكيمياء او البينج بونج ما بينهم
ليطلع المشهد بشكل اللطيف المشاهدين
ماخذين عنك انطباع يا منذر انك شخصيه
شريره من مسلسلاتك بدي اطمنهم ابشرها منك
في الواقع شخصيه جدا
طيب انت تتجسد في مسلسل جديد شخصيه شوقي
فتح الله شخصيه شريره كمان في رمضان ولا
شيء جديد شوفي الكل بيحكي بس والله انا
شايف عنده وجهه نظر هو مرات وهي صعبه
الناس
عدا اصعب الادوار في التمثيل وخط البياني
مش واضح مرات الناس
في الحياه او في الدراما بتتحاسبي على رده
الفعل
يعني على رده فعلك انتم ما لكم علاقه في
رده فعل انتم علاقه في الفعل في حاله انا
كنت صاحب الفعل فهون احاكم فانت بتتحاكمي
على رده الفعل وينسوا الفاعل اوكي بحكي لك
حتى لو عملوا واحد اثنين ثلاثه ما بصيرش
تعمل واحد اثنين ثلاثه طب هو بالاساس
بالحياه والله العظيم انه حتى لو عمل هيك
انه لبسي يعني
رده فعلي لا لا على اساس الفعل بس بدي
اقول لك شغله هل بتشعر انه انت شكلك بساعد
انه دائما بتاخد دور الرجل الخطير الرجل
المافيا يعني كانه صار منذر رياحني محصور
بهذه الادوار الشريره الخطيره شكلك
من من الابواب الصعبه في التمثيل هاي
الادوار ولكن انا عملت يعني ادوار خير
محدش شافها ههه
ما حد شافه
عصيه طيبه ولا شريره لا كل شخصيه لكل
شخصيه لها ابوابها ولكن على فكره مش
الشخصيه الشريره دائما يعني والشخصيه اللي
انظلم فنتيجه هذا الظلم راح على اماكن
ثانيه
تحاسب عليها بشكل مش لطيف يعني طيب منذر
اليوم احنا بنشوف المسلسل بصيغته الاخيره
دائما كمشاهدين بس اكيد في الكواليس في
قصص وحكايات لا نعرفها ولا ندري عنها
واكيد بتخيل يعني انت ومحمد رمضان شو ممكن
يصير كثير عنده فضول اعرف هل في قصص صارت
هيك تخبرنا عنها حصريا بمصر
لا في مشاهد يعني
يعني من من باب المرح مثلا في لحظات في
الاكشن اللي هو
قتلوا بعض بجد
من الكواليس والله العظيم
والله يعني كان في بلحظات الا يعني تحصل
يعني فريمين يكون فيها ضربه بشكل فعلي